okay thanks Costas and thanks for having
me and I want to thank Eric for his
excellent talk because it also helps set
the context for a lot of what I'll be
discussing here you can think about much
of what I'm going to talk about today
about what it's like to sort of live on
the other side of these exchanges and to
deal with hfts and other counterparties
as well I also should say that there's
really going to be no explicit game
theoretic content in this talk which
Costas promised me was okay but there
will be quite a bit of practice as many
of you know I for the last 12 years or
so I've been working with a quantitative
trading group on Wall Street in my sort
of shadow life and I want to give
special thanks to my trading partner you
know by vaca who's a co-author on all
this work all this work kind of came out
of some proprietary commercial context
in our training group and the parts of
that I'm talking about are sort of the
non-proprietary parts that seem
scientifically interesting to us over
time and so you know this slide sort of
puts a lot of this is kind of just a
context slide for a lot of the things
that Eric said we certainly live in
interesting times on Wall Street both
from a technological perspective and
also more generally from a social
perspective so here's the same image
that showed of the flash crash a few
years ago here's the famous book by
Michael Lewis which I highly recommend
on high-frequency trading
we have Bernie Madoff other insider
traders and the like and so without
passing moral judgment on any of this
activity including high-frequency
traders what I want to do in this talk
is just lay out what some of the
algorithmic challenges are in trading in
modern electronic financial markets from
the perspective of somebody in working
in a quantitative trading group
essentially something like a traditional
stat our equities trading group what we
do in my group is trade equities long
and short we trade pretty much every
liquid instrument in many many markets
both domestically and internationally
then we hedge exclusively with futures
so we're not doing any complicated
derivatives or the like so we're in kind
of the simplest markets or the simplest
instruments but as Erika sort of already
outlined today a lot of the complexity
of trading those environments
today comes from the automation of those
markets and the data that's available
and what you do with it and what your
counterparties do with it as well and
needless to say because of the rising
automation and availability of data on
Wall Street's there are many many
trading problems that one encounters
that invite a learning approach a
machine learning approach right because
you have the data it's at a temporal and
spacial scale that you can't understand
as a human being and so one has to
develop algorithms to trade sensibly and
those algorithms have to be adaptive and
trained or should be trained on
historical data sometimes a lot of
historical data including very very
recent data and so what I'm going to do
is just try to give a high-level talk
where I quickly outline three sort of
little vignettes or case studies of
specific problems that kind of arise in
trading algorithmic trading in modern
electronic markets and sort of what the
challenge is those problems present for
kind of traditional machine learning are
and some kind of hints about how you can
address those problems with new
techniques and so the first two problems
I'm going to talk about the first ones
probably the first two are quite closely
related to sort of the world that Eric
was describing are both about problems
of optimized execution where a person or
a model or an algorithm has made a
decision to execute some tray to like
buy you know a hundred thousand shares
of Google or short you know a hundred
thousand shares of Yahoo what have you
and now the problem is actually
executing that trade because a directive
like that is under specified in
particular it's under specified in its
temporal aspects right so you use you
know I can say I want to buy a hundreds
of thousand shares of something but how
quickly do I want to do that okay
and so as we'll see that there's this
trade-off in all electronic markets and
by the way I don't think any of this
would go away with something like the
very sensible alternative mechanisms
that Eric is proposing you have this
trade-off between immediacy and price
you can be in a hurry and impact prices
more and get worse prices but you might
want to do that because let's say you
think that the informational advantage
you have is fleeting and you want to
execute the trade quickly or
you can try to do things in a more
leisurely way and try to let the market
come to your preferred price but then
it'll take longer in general okay and so
the first two problems I'm going to talk
about are sort of very specific
instances of that kind of immediacy
versus price trade-off that you see in
electronic markets the last one is a
little bit more on kind of algorithmic
versions of kind of classical portfolio
optimization mean-variance optimization
the kinds of problems where you want to
hold a diversified portfolio that you
know kind of maximizes your return
subject to some risk considerations or
volatility considerations okay and I may
not finish all this but I'll hopefully
at least say a few words about all these
topics but I think I did save some time
because Eric very nicely laid out kind
of what the modern continuous double
limit order auction looks like this is
what's sometimes referred to in
financial circles as Mike market
microstructure and and so let me start
off by just describing the canonical
trading problem we already mentioned it
but let me make it a little bit more
formal suppose that we have a particular
trading goal like we want to sell the
shares of some stocks buy or sell a
symmetric but just to be concrete let's
say that we want to sell a certain
number of shares some volume that I'll
call capital V and I also have a
specified time horizon in which I want
to execute that trade so in I want to
sell the shares in tea time steps and of
course if I'm selling I want to maximize
the revenue from those shares and if I'm
buying I want to minimize the
expenditure for those shares and as you
might or might not imagine there's sort
of a very large number of benchmarks
that have been proposed for how to
measure the quality of such a trade so
if I actually go out in the market and
execute an order to let's say you know
buy a certain number of shares of Google
in a specified time period we have to
ask well you know how good how well did
I perform right and almost all of the
sensible measures kind of measure your
performance relative to the activity
that was going on in the market at the
time that you executed your trade so a
very typical thing would to do would be
to say let's say I started this trade at
10 o'clock in the morning I executed it
over the course of an hour how well did
the actual
average share price that I got in my
execution compared to let's say the
volume weighted average price of the
stock during that same period that's
called the V whap there's something
called the T whap I'm in this particular
case going to use something that's
called the implementation shortfall
which is you look at the midpoint
between the bid and the ask at the time
you started your trade and which of
course by the way is itself a fictitious
benchmark because by definition there's
no liquidity at the midpoint between the
bid and the ask but it sort of seems
like a fair peg point and then I compare
my performance to that and and and ask
you know how much worse I did than that
it will almost always be worse on
average than then the midpoint of the
dead-ass because you know you know in
all these problems your trading activity
itself is going to push the prices in
the direction that disfavors you okay if
I buy by buying a large volume of shares
it's going to push the price up if I'm
selling it's going to push the price
down and this is entirely do go it's
it's at least largely due to just the
mechanical impact I have on the order
book right as I cross the spread and eat
liquidity from the other side it you
know it makes the successive prices
worse and worse okay so whatever metric
you look at it's very if you if any of
you thought about this problem seriously
for just a little while you'd come to
the view that a very natural framework
to think about such problems is
essentially problems of state-based
control okay where there are at least
two very very obvious state variables
you want to consider how much inventory
you have remaining
ie how many of the V shares do you still
have left to buy in the given time
period and how much time is left okay
and you might also want to think about
other features or state variables that
capture other kinds of market Civet e
market activity that might have
informational advantage as well okay so
this is just a snapshot sort of showing
what a typical order book looks like
this is from many many years ago in
Microsoft on-on-on
Island at the time which has now been
rolled up into some larger exchange but
you see the buy orders arranged but in
order of decreasing price the sell
orders arranged in
ascending price by definition there's
always going to be a gap between these
two which is the bid-ask spread that
Eric was discussing there's volumes at
each of these and just to remind you
that the way these markets work is you
know if I'm trying to let's say buy
shares I can you know I can I can place
a limit order and that limit order will
either you know sort of sit somewhere in
this price ladder or it might actually
cross the spread and execute against the
existing liquidity on the sell book okay
and it might partially match so if I put
in an order for I don't know let's say a
thousand shares at you know twenty three
seven seventy nine nine I would execute
nine hundred of those shares the first
hundred at this price the next eight
hundred at this price and then the my
remaining hundred shares would down
become the new top of the buy book okay
so it's a very mechanical process and as
Eric pointed out it's extremely volatile
these days it's extremely dynamic the
sort of time scale at which orders
arrive and executions take place is you
know often at the sub millisecond level
in highly liquid stocks or even the
microseconds and as he mentioned also
right you know everything is possible I
can cancel I can revise my order partial
executions may occur and so you know one
very interesting very difficult question
or type of research to ask is how do
individual you know sort of microscopic
orders influence aggregate macro
behavior you know of the overall
aggregate market but from the purposes
of a trading group like our is one of
the things we care about most is this
trade-off between immediacy and price so
you know to just you know I won't
explain this chart in any detail but
what it's showing you the x-axis is sort
of you know what my limit order price is
let's say if I'm buying right and at the
left extreme I'm sort of considering
prices that are sitting way down in the
book so they're very very far from where
the market is currently trading and so
what I'm showing you here is the
performance of a very simple class of
strategies for this problem of execute v
shares and tea time steps which is what
I call kind of submit and leave
strategies okay and in a submit and
leave strategy what you do is you just
pick a fixed limit order price put
all these years at that limit order
price hope that they get executed but
any volume that's not executed after the
T times to share steps you have to cross
the spread and eat the beat and buy the
shares at whatever prices they're
offered on the other side of the book
okay because in all of these you know
it's it's it's very as a practical
matter it's very much the case that
whenever we execute a trade we always
set a time limit on it because we
essentially have some model or empirical
measurement historically of how long our
informational advantage lasts right so
if an analyst upgrades a stock for
instance there's some informational
advantage in trading on that activity on
that upgrade very very quickly but you
know after five minutes it's gone
because the markets essentially already
incorporated that news okay so what you
see here is that there's this very
distinct peak if I put my orders very
deep down in the book then nothing gets
executed I have to cross the spread all
at the end and pay the prices on offer
at the other extreme I could cross the
spread at the beginning right and pray
pay the prices on offer at the beginning
these two things are roughly equal but
you can see that there's a great deal of
optimization there's sort of a magic
price at which I should put my limit
order if all I'm going to do is leave it
there and then cross the spread with the
remaining inventory at the end of the
time interval okay so this already shows
you that even within this kind of
brain-dead class of strategies there's
actually quite a bit of optimization to
do right there's a very very sharp peak
and this is quite this is quite typical
I don't remember what stock this is in
yeah she should know so in everything
I'm going to describe here I'm sort of
only accounting for the mechanical
impact and the mechanical impact is the
only thing you can kind of optimize for
using historical data right because by
definition you can't ask the
counterfactual question of what would
the psychological or if you like you
know the sort of non mechanical impact
be I mean you you can have models for it
and there are many models proposed in
the literature but for from the
viewpoint of a group like ours I mean we
don't even bother looking at it in those
models because we know that at the end
of the day the only way you're going to
measure that is by actually starting to
trade right and so of course we do that
in small volumes at the beginning when
we're trying
they knew and gradually ramp it up as we
get some empirical sense of what that
impact is like and as you can imagine
right I mean all these things have to do
with liquidity it's much easier to hide
your activity and have it have lower
mechanical impact and kind of
counterfactual impact in a highly liquid
name than what than something that
trades very infrequently okay
this is for some specific stock for some
specific period but this is extremely
generic right if you go to any
reasonably liquid stock you would see
that there's really and you'll exact the
exact location like this zero here means
kind of putting your order at the
current bit or the ask so being you know
kind of putting your order not crossing
the spread but not sitting down too far
right so because you know in a highly
illiquid stock if you sit down too far
on average you're just never going to
get executed because you know even if a
little bit of liquidity gets eaten away
other counterparties are just filling
that vacuum behind it okay
so it's there it's always you know modal
and it's and it always has a relatively
sharp peak exactly where that peak is
might depend on the stock in question
but it's a very generic empirical figure
okay so you know reinforcement learning
which is essentially the AI term for you
know discrete state-based control is
sort of a perfect fit for solving this
kind of problem where as a first cut
what you might do is just say alright
I'm going to keep track of two things
the amount of inventory I have remaining
and how much time I have remaining and
whatever period I've specified over
which I want to do the trade and I won't
go into it but we did you know many
years ago this sort of large-scale
empirical study where we apply kind of
fairly generic reinforcement learning
using historical data to learn kind of
optimized policies using those two state
variables and you know the kind of
takeaway message here is you learn very
sensible policies and this is what you
want right I mean you kind of want you
know in general I mean we're kind of the
opposite of blackbox quants any time we
use machine learning in a trading
problem or in in some kind of strategy
model if we can't back out in our heads
some reason
of all kind of economic rationale for
why this makes sense we're extremely
uncomfortable deploying it in actual
trading and so what you want to kind of
see our pictures like this I'm showing
you the actual policies learned over
three relatively liquid NASDAQ stocks
where the state very the state space is
sort of on the XY plane where you have a
certain amount of time left I've
discretized the variables here so this
is sort of decreasing amounts of time
left in your interval and decreasing
amounts of inventory left in the size of
the trade that you're trying to execute
and basically the the sort of z axis
here is measuring you know whether
you're you know kind of sitting further
back in the book versus crossing the
spread so the higher the value means the
more you're kind of crossing the bid the
higher the price you're buying right
you're trying to cross the spread and
you can see here you know very sensible
behavior as you're running out of time
and you have a lot of inventory left
then you better get going and start
being more aggressive in your trades if
you've got a lot of time left and very
inventory very little inventory so this
might have happened because you know at
the beginning some other counterparty
kind of cross the spread and executed a
lot of your shares very early in the
interval well now you can afford to be
patient right now you can afford to drop
down in the book and hope for price
improvement and get a better price okay
so you know so if you do this across
many many different stocks and then over
many many different historical periods
you will always get kind of a shape that
looks like this but the details really
matter here right the numerical details
really matter because different stocks
have different bid-ask spreads you know
the this sort of price you know the
bid-ask spread determines how big you
have to be um you know what how large
your price has to be a you know above
the bid to actually reach the buyers or
the sellers on the other side etc okay
so this is all kind of good news yeah
these deadlines an example would be like
we said the analyst
yeah yeah and these and these volumes
and you know sort of to talk about the
practice of a little bit more these
volumes and these time intervals we
would kind of self impose them now we
might optimize them right because
everything here is a moving part that
interacts with everything else so for
instance and and this is the kind of
thing we're always trading off you know
we might know that we can kind of on
average get better prices by taking a
longer time interval but then we'll also
know there's a you know essentially a
decay of what you would call our alpha
on Wall Street like our even for our
informational advantage right and so we
will always be trading those two things
off and testing them on historical data
to the extent that we can and then it's
better then at some point you have to
you know we have to either you know if
we're using kind of direct market access
algorithms or if we're trading through a
prime brokerage we have to have a
directive right you you kind of can't
say to the brokerage or you definitely
don't want to say to the brokerage oh
you know why don't you buy you know some
Google shares over whatever amount of
time you feel like it right we have to
actually give them a very specific
directive that some more complex would
be some kind of learning model where as
this is happening you might detect
things at once that will make you want
to change your time limit right
potentially potentially yeah yeah yeah
and and by the way I mean like one form
of that for instance is it's quite often
that one aunt when one analyst upgrades
their view on a stock other analysts
upgrade their view on that same stock in
quick succession and so one of the
things you need to decide there is like
is that actually fresh news or is this
just kind of an artifact of some other
more basic news that's getting into the
market and then you might want in that
case you might not even want to trade on
it at all yeah why at the end of you
here you want to buy the rest of the
volume why not just give up time for
questions I mean the high level answer
okay so there's two answers to this one
is if you're an actual brokerage like
Bank of America and you have an
algorithmic trading desk you're
performing these actions on behalf of a
client that's given you the directive
right and so you don't ask well you know
hey I didn't get all your shares of
Google do you sure you still want to buy
them they you know the language in which
they communicate with you is as a
directive to buy this many shares in
this amount of time from our standpoint
we do have that option but the reason we
don't is because at some point we've
kind of optimized all of these things
together and realize that you know this
is sort of the right amount of volume to
buy based on this informational signal
and by the way that volume is sort of
usually the maximum that we think we can
get away with without pushing prices
around too much so you could do
something like what you're suggesting
but I think you know as a practical
matter we you know there's sort of so
many things to think about in this world
that the fewer moving free parameters
you can have the better yeah the coz of
factual maca typing you know it seems to
be a big problem in my mind when you
when you do the testing on the six
months following are you doing that live
right that's still you think the model
is still using so this is you know you
can think about this study is limiting
the sort of scope to the improvements
you can get on that particular kind of
market impact okay and in general you
know as a practical matter the way we
deal with the second kind of impact is
by you know I mean first of all we have
many rules in fact we even have like
contractual regulations on how much of
all you know sort of how many how much
volume we can trade in any particular
stock okay so for instance my specific
group you know we will never be more
that I mean we have a contractual limit
that says we will never constitute more
than one percent of the average daily
volume in any single stock but we don't
even ever want to get close to that we
will we will sometimes be a half a
percent and what by the way we're not an
especially large group right so there
are a lot of groups with this sort of
behavior that they're willing to be that
were you know like a quarter of half a
percent of the average daily
vol yeah so I'm very happy to see that
you're talking about a glass box rather
than a black box much burning and I
guess this being able to for human
beings to be able to understand what is
going on
I wonder given the complexity of what's
being learned the special tools you have
to explain these policies to people is
that more done by eyeballing I mean in
the case of a problem like this it's
very clear what sort of sensible
behavior means right if I somehow the
learning process told me oh you're
you're running out of time you have a
huge amount of inventory left and so you
know reduce your buy price lower this is
kind of obvious the harder thing is when
you have strategies that work well and
you don't quite you know work well
historically maybe they are even working
well in live training and you don't have
a clear handle and and you know and so
here I mean I think this is the nature
of the problem makes what's sensible
clear other times you we find ourselves
admittedly kind of thinking about almost
thinking about it from an
anthropological perspective which is
like you know if this trade is
consistently making money there's got to
be some other group of counterparties
out there that are you know are taking
the other side of this trade and what
you know what is the reason you know
what is their reason for persistently
doing this you know other other than you
know stupidity right and actually you're
worried if the other if the reason is
stupidity right because people real you
know people often realize that they're
doing something stupid and stop doing it
and then you can lose a lot of money but
if there's sort of a good reason why I
mean so like to give a concrete example
it's very consistently you can very
consistently make small amounts of money
by in the period before the market opens
laying down a ladder of limit orders on
both side of the books in every liquid
stock but spaced far enough that if your
first order gets hit it's a significant
kind of opening you know ten minute
deviation for that stock okay and if
your second order gets hit it's like a
you know an even larger standard
deviation so basically just laying down
these
orders on both sides of the books seeing
if anything gets hit and then
liquidating it over let's say the first
two hours after the market open very
consistently makes money it's not easy
to implement this in kind of you know
there's a lot I'm the reason I'm telling
you this is that I know that the
engineering details of this are
non-trivial
but but so the reason why because so why
is this well the reason is that many
parties that sort of trade on a slower
time scale like mutual fund managers
first of all they like to trade at the
open of the close to try to benchmark to
opening and closing prices because
that's how their performance is
benchmark a and B right there often
reacting to overnight news right and so
they're all coming in the morning but
but it's sort of worthwhile for them to
do so because they want to get it close
to the opener to the close the same
thing works on the close as well so
there it's not sort of like there's an
obvious optimization criteria and
there's a sensible behavior to it but
it's there's more of a sociological
exclamation to it okay so now I mean
already you know again just on this
aspect of mechanical market impact if
you compared you know sort of how well
you can do by keeping track of these two
simple state variables and taking kind
of a control theoretic approach versus
let's say the best you could have done
by optimizing within this class of
submit and leave strategies right which
don't know about time and remain volume
remaining they just keep an order fixed
and then when time runs out they cross
the spread you can all you're already
getting 35 percent improvement on
average using this kind of approach
compared to that and this is a
meaningful improvement in this world
because you know as think as Eric
mentioned right you know kind of on this
particular problem performance Delta's
like sort of you know the the sort of
meaningful improvements in performance
are measured in basis points which are
hundred hundreds of a percentage point
right so if you're sort of getting
thirty five percent improvement over
something reasonable it's non-trivial
yeah so there's something to leave here
in comparison is measured without some
Italy price is optimized really high
side yes so it's like a learning to
learning experiment so either do
reinforcement learning on the historical
data or use the historical data to find
the best single limit order price within
this restrict
class of strategies you already get a
thirty five percent improvement but the
reinforcement learning is that also
giving insight going on so it's all
train test methodology we take a period
of historical data we train
reinforcement learning learn some policy
on that historical period over the same
historical period we find the optimize
submit and leave strategy we compare
both of them on this excessive
out-of-sample time period you're getting
a thirty five percent improvement one
days like information chained to the
market or you can be like you're saying
basic like any arbitrary interval okay
so so I mean these experiments we did
over a long historical period with many
many kind of sliding windows of training
and testing data to get you know to get
into the details a little bit one that
one of the things that's hard in
applying machine learning to financial
or market data is the fact that if
you're not careful you can learn
unintentionally all kinds of like you
know just sort of drift okay so if you
happen to train over a period in which
the market is just rising overall you
know you'll learn a policy that you know
basically just says you know you should
you know you should buy right because
the market is rising at a high level
right and you don't want to learn this
kind of drift you can also you know
learn other sorts of seasonality x'
which by which I don't mean you know
fall/winter but other kinds of you know
different trading days have different
volumes different periods of the day
have more or less trading activity and
so you want there's a lot of engineering
that kind of goes into kind of creating
your models in a way that make sure
you're not just learning these
seasonality x' or these you know kind of
directional drifts okay so you know it's
of course natural to ask once you see
that this sort of simple control
theoretic state-based approach works you
know reasonably well to ask well maybe I
should add other state variables which
don't just have to do with how much time
and volume are remaining but that are
actually looking at you know what's
going on in the market and since we're
in kind of a double limit order book
Oh structure setting it's quite natural
to look at features of the order book
itself right or the recent temporal
activity in your book and by the way I
am of the belief or kind of semi
knowledge that I think a lot of hft
firms who are not trying to solve
execution problems per se they're
actually trying to predict directional
movement in the market right but I think
they're using a lot of the same kind of
machine learning techniques I think
they're spending a lot of time sitting
around inventing features of the order
books that might have some slight
informational advantage and let's say
predicting whether the midpoint of the
spread is going to go up or down in the
next 500 milliseconds for instance okay
it's not easy work and it requires sort
of technology that's not really in our
domain so we don't do that kind of thing
but I think the methods are very much
the same and I won't go into this I
think so yeah I mean I think especially
at the micro structural level you kind
of have to be right because there's no I
mean at some level it's not you know
there's you you can't really understand
it right it really has to do with sort
of volumes and speeds of data that are
beyond kind of normal human
comprehension and so you mean you can be
very careful about your train and
testing methodology and sort of know
that's there's some consistent
predictive power to some state variable
but knowing Y is very very hard at that
granularity right so this is just
showing you a list of a bunch of kind of
features of the order book that we
invented and add it to this basic state
space of time and volume remaining and
the percentage improvement that you get
by adding them I'm not going to go into
all of them but you know a lot of them
are quite straightforward like what is
the bid-ask spread right so knowing what
the bid-ask spread is at a given moment
is a very valuable thing to incorporate
into the state space because in
particular you know implicitly now the
policy can learn exactly how high a
price it needs to put in to just get to
the bid and not let's say overshoot the
bid by a lot right because if I
basically say like well I'm going to
raise my current price by 15 cents like
well it is that 15 cents just reaching
the other side and eating a
little bit of volume or is it actually
crossing very deep into the book and
giving me terrible terrible prices
things like signing trades is very
useful signing trades is basically going
through the order books and saying
whether each trade was initiated by a
buyer crossing the spread to the sell
book or a seller crossing the book - the
Bible so you know and some of these
things right actually don't help you
that much so we thought it would be
helpful to know exactly how much volume
there is at the bit or the ask it turns
out this is not I mean it looks slightly
harmful but it's basically a wash it
doesn't seem to have much informational
value negative actually means that you
know in the experiments it's slightly
hurt performance to add that feature to
the state space and this could just be
for overfitting reasons right like I if
I add some variable which doesn't have
any informational value then you know my
model in training will you know fit kind
of to the behavior of that variable but
it's not useful out-of-sample but you
know it turns out that you know if you
take kind of the best of these features
that did add informational value and
combine them you get kind of another
thirteen percent improvement over and
above the thirty five percent
improvement that I described on the last
slide okay okay good so you know just
again to kind of riff or freeride on
Eric's talk one of the things that's
kind of very interesting about modern
financial markets and their evolution
over the last 20 years or so is that you
know again as he kind of intimated
sometimes in kind of going to automation
in apparent and transparency actually
there was some kind of human aspect of
prior trading that served a very useful
purpose that was eradicated and you know
it made certain types of trade much more
difficult and then some new electronic
mechanism was introduced to try to
replicate that functionality before and
so an example of that is you know again
you know this picture of a double of
continuous double limit order book this
has been around since sort of the dawn
of financial markets it's just that
prior to automation on Wall Street for
instance you know it would actually be
maintained in a paper
Leger by the market maker in that stock
who would sort of you know have these
little shits of paper and order them you
know in order of increasing or
decreasing price whether on the buyer of
the sell book and and so that we're
going to do there wasn't this kind of
transparency but with this kind of
transparency where this data is freely
available to you know anybody who wants
to can do you know real-time
reconstruction of limit order books and
see kind of the trades of everybody else
not not earmarked by identity right
you're not you're not being told oh this
is a credit suisse order and this is
from sa C capital or something like that
but you can definitely algorithmically
detect for instance when there's a large
trade in the market when somebody's
trying to let's say unload a lot of some
stock in some small amount of time you
know the way they have to do it is
through a market like this and they're
going to leave an algorithmic trace of
their activity in the data okay so in
the old days when let's say I'm you know
suppose there's some mutual fund manager
who's you know life goal is to track the
S&P 500 okay and you know because of
because of you know volatility in the
market you know let's say for instance
Johnson & Johnson has done
extraordinarily well and now because
Johnson & Johnson has done
extraordinarily well they're overweight
Johnson & Johnson right they're out of
alignment with the S&P 500 so they need
to unload some Johnson & Johnson and
they're like a fidelity or Vanguard fund
manager so actually their portfolio is
so big that they let's say you know they
have 1 percent of the outstanding shares
of Johnson & Johnson a huge stake in a
public company and they need to reduce
it to you know like 0.8 you know 0.8
percent instead okay this is a massive
massive trade and the way the mutual
fund manager would have done this prior
to automation is they would have it
would have been sort of an off the floor
or what they would call an upstairs
trade they would actually call you know
a somebody at a brokerage they would
call one of their buddies at a brokerage
or multiple brokerages and they would
say look I've got this rather difficult
trade I don't want to execute it on the
floor of the exchange because it'll just
be too obvious what I'm trying to do and
you know prices will move against me you
know could you possibly shop around and
see if there's a counter
maybe there's somebody at maybe there's
somebody else out there that happens to
want to buy you know 0.2 of a percent of
all Johnson & Johnson outstanding shares
so that we can kind of there would still
be a record of it eventually at the end
of the day or the end of the trade it
just wouldn't have taken place on the
floor of the exchange would have taken
place by people making phone calls and
saying okay I found a counterparty for
you at this hedge fund or this other
investment firm okay that kind of got
eradicated when the world went like this
and all the activity had to be executed
through these books in electronic
fashion in order to get competitive
prices and this was sort of the initial
impetus to what are called dark pools
okay so what are dark pools dark pools
are another very recent kind of
electronic exchange I think the first
one's kind of probably came out about 10
years ago but they became quite
widespread about five years ago they
were essentially they were introduced to
sort of deal with this thing that went
away that I described to allow large
counterparties to sort of trade with
each other at minimal market impact okay
and the interesting thing about dark
pools is that unlike the double limit
order book you don't specify price and
volume the way you do in a limit order
you just specify volume you just say
this is the volume and I'm and whether
you're a buyer or seller you're not
specifying the price and so now it's
sort of buyers and sellers instead of it
sort of being ordered by price or
instead ordered by time of arrival so
you just have these two queues of
arriving buyers and sellers you just
line them up in the order that they
arrive as long as there are parties on
both sides you just keep matching them
together okay and now the question is
like well if they're just ordered by by
arrival time and with there's no price
specified when I match a buyer and a
seller what price does that transaction
take place that it basically takes place
at the the the midpoint of the so-called
NB bo which is essentially the midpoint
of the litt double limit order book
market in the US okay so this is the
whole point here right you don't go to a
dark pool looking for a price
improvement you don't go there with the
thought like oh I'm going to actually
get a better price here that I could get
by trading on the open limit order book
you go there because you're perfectly
happy with the prices offered on the lid
market you're just worried that you
would never be able to get them because
you'd so quickly push the price in the
wrong direction because of the volume of
your trade so you're sort of have these
this exchange now that's pegged to an
existing exchange the so called lit
market these are called dark right
because you don't really see you don't
see any of the activity you just put
yourself in this line and you know
you're just told in each second you know
nothing yet nothing yet nothing yet okay
your trades executed and here's the
price that you've got and that price
should be pegged to the the lit market
okay so it's you know this was such a
popular idea that there are now dozens
or you know many dozens of dark pools in
the United States and they're
essentially you go there to compete for
liquidity to get liquidity not to
compete for price and so this you know
generates kind of another interesting
kind of optimized execution problem
we're instead of trying to optimize the
performance of your trade over time as
in the problem I described before you're
essentially trying to break it up over
space or more precisely over exchanges
okay so in other words the the problem
that's known as smart order routing on
Wall Street is you have these multiple
exchange let's say you have K different
dark pools and you have a certain volume
of let's say Johnson & Johnson shares
that you want to sell okay
and at each time step you need to decide
well of my remaining inventory how
should I charge a distributed among
these multiple exchanges to try to
maximize the fraction of my remaining
inventory that's executed at each step
right so it's again a problem of an you
have a well specified trade I want to
buy or sell the shares of something but
now instead of trying to get the boss
the best possible prices I'm just trying
to as quickly as possible
unload this inventory by dispersing it
or routing it to these multiple
exchanges okay so we thought about this
problem from a theoretical standpoint
and that led to kind of an interesting
algorithm
a solution that we evaluated
experimentally I don't have time to go
into the details but you know here's one
simple cartoon model of liquidity right
so these so maybe I should have stayed
this explicitly different dark pools
will have different sort of liquidity
properties at different times and for
different stocks okay so for instance
it's quite common when a new exchange
starts whether it's a limit order book
or a dark pool
that they'll try to actually get a
foothold in the market by offering
preferential treatment or rebates or
fees to some particular class of stocks
so you know you will actually see
marketing materials that say well you
know if you're trading mid-cap consumer
durable stocks you know we are the dark
pool you want to come to that's where
people who want to trade consumer
durable stocks are coming and so this is
where your counterparties are don't go
to other dark pools because you'll just
be sitting there waiting for your trade
to get executed whereas you know in
these stocks the action is you know if
the action is at our dark pool okay so
you know one kind of cartoon model of
this is to imagine that at each times
that there's some underlying stationary
probability distribution for a given
stock let's say Johnson & Johnson the
different dark pools will have sort of
different liquidity profiles meaning and
and and so what I mean by this is that
let's imagine that on the x axis is
number of shares okay and on the y axis
is sort of probability that that number
of shares is available for execution on
the other side at each given time step
so more formally what I have in mind is
that you know if we submit the shares of
our trade so let's say this particular
dark pool that what happens is that we
draw a number according to this
distribution we draw s according to this
distribution okay and that's sort of the
the volume of the counterparty on the
other side in this dark pool at that
particular discretized time step and so
then what gets would get executed of
course is actually the minimum of vns
right because you're never going to
execute more than you asked for you
might execute less so if I submit an
order to this dark pool to buy a hundred
thousand shares and s gets drawn and
it's a million then I'll just be told
your hundred thousand shares were
executed okay but if I submitted a
hundred thousand shares and s was the
desk that was drawn was fifty thousand
I'll be told half of your order was
executed half of it's still waiting in
line okay okay so yeah so here you can
partial execution but how can that curb
then be non decreasing um
this curve is just showing you you know
so this is a curve showing you know
modeling the idea that you know volume
is kind of in this range are quite
likely to be available okay whereas you
know larger volumes are not available
right if you do partial execution should
it get a machine curve either so the
partial execution is sort of on my side
right so I submit a volume a number is
drawn which is the volume available on
the other side the minimum of the two
quantities is what's executed and then I
still have that remaining inventory that
at the next time step I need to try to
execute yeah I thought you were asking
more of a mechanism question than a math
question it's a density it's a density
not a it's a you know PDF not a CDF yeah
Kevin stable for there to be so many jar
cool isn't it everyone's interested
these are good questions I mean I'm sure
Eric has thoughts on this and I'm not
sure I think Ramesh isn't here but I
know he's thought about kind of these
questions why is there a mean it's the
same thing with you know it's the same
thing that happened under the sort of
you know kind of regulation of financial
markets there's this famous kind of
incident called or you know kind of
regulatory ruling called Reagan and NMS
which is national market system and and
I'm not sure it's an equilibrium but
there does seem to be this proliferation
and they compete with each other in
various ways I mean it's a good question
whether or not at some point this will
shake out and you know there will only
be one dark bull or only a couple this
hasn't you know this hasn't really
happened in lit in in sort of the
continuous double auction either since
they sort of I mean by the way it used
to be the case that regular
too early you know your stock could only
trade on the exchange it was listed and
this was sort of the golden ear of
specialists and the like so if your
company listed on the New York Stock
Exchange the only place to buy or sell
shares was on the floor of the New York
Stock Exchange so when this got
deregulated and basically anybody any
startup if you like with the know-how
and the ability to get the regulatory
approvals could open up shop and say hey
we're running a double you know is I
mean I think to Eric's point it's a very
interesting time because the regulatory
landscape is such that you know startup
companies can you know propose brand new
mechanisms right like the one Eric's
proposing what you're doing here is the
endpoint the only ones are for the
trends in it you know from a from a
conceptual standpoint I want to agree
with you but so many things in the
actual world of financial markets are
obviously out of equilibrium in some
sense and so you know how to explain
that it could be not everybody's doing
what I'm proposing here that they're
doing it in different ways and by the
way I mean to you know the I think on
this question is sort of what does game
theory have to say about financial
markets I think it's very difficult but
at a high level you know we think all
the time one of the things we're worried
about is how many other people or groups
are doing something like what we're
doing right because any given trade has
a certain capacity right you can't sort
of execute arbitrary volumes so if we're
all doing the same thing then our
respective piece of that trade or its
profitability is definitely going to
decline so we don't enough time we have
it understand so let's take further
questions all right so let's how much
time do I have is it actually zero or
let me just finish this one vignette and
I'll skip the last one and then we can
we can plug it so it turns out that you
know in this simple formalism that I
just described if you kind of specify it
there's actually a very simple and nice
algorithm that you can use so so first
of all the sort of real machine learning
challenge that comes up in this model is
the fact that you're your observations
are censored by your own actions right
so it's this thing that if you submit a
thousand
you get more than a thousand you don't
know actually might they're more you
know a million and you want to kind of
know that because you're deciding how to
distribute your order over these
multiple exchanges and if you just ask
the question what well suppose I wanted
to estimate these probability
distributions from my censored
observations there's a well known
maximum likelihood estimator for this
which is called the kaplan-meier
estimator or sometimes called the
product limit estimator but we have an
exploration problem here as well right
we basically want to learn just enough
about each of these pools to execute our
trade optimally so if I'm never
executing sort of orders of more than a
hundred thousand shares I don't need to
know what the probability of a 10
million share order getting executed I
sort of only need to know it up to a
certain prefix so there's a very simple
and appealing algorithm that kind of has
a bit of an e/m flavor to it which is
you basically just start you know you
just start trading let's say at the
beginning distributing your orders
uniformly over all of the different dark
pools then you start getting information
about them and you can for each one of
them form the kaplan-meier estimator of
that the distribution of liquidity
behind outdoor pool it's wrong of course
okay but then you could just pretend
that it's right and do optimal
allocation with respect to those
estimated distributions when you do that
of course you will then get new
information based on the orders that you
submit it and then you can just rest
emits a simple you know do greedy
allocation under your current
distributional estimates then r es
tomates
with the results of the next round of
executions and one can prove that this
converges quickly you know with a
polynomial rate of convergence to the
optimal allocations that you would have
made if you knew the a distributions
from the start and you know it if for
those of you that know a little bit of
the reinforcement learning literature
the analysis of this is actually quite
reminiscent of the analysis of things
like e e cubed and r max which are sort
of provably convergent algorithms for
learning and markov decision processes
here we don't have a Markov decision
process but the state is sort of our
informational state about the different
liquidities of the different exchanges
rather than an actual
okay so I had another vignette that I
won't talk about but you can go look on
the slides at the pointer to the paper
at lease and let me stop there and take
any questions if there's time or we can
just morph into lunch connection between
your paper and Eric's and a way to put
it together to make it relevant for
ultimately so obviously you're not the
only one doing this on the street and
there but there are a finite number a
relatively small number of hft adoptive
doing this so that means that you can
actually run a very simple simulation
where suppose that you're not the only
one using your algorithm what if there
are another two or three other players
are using similar algorithms but perhaps
have different slightly different parts
of the data can you figure out what that
interaction might produce in terms of
the outcome of prices not mathematically
but computationally and then to connect
it to Eric's paper you can ask ask the
question what different market
structures with different kinds of
algorithms are going to be ideally
suited for market stability versus
fragmentation all the issues that
regulators care about and then start
asking more sophisticated questions
about how markets structure and
algorithms interact so it almost seem
like you can combine what you're doing
with what Eric is doing in a way that
could be really interesting yeah I mean
I mean certainly one could do
simulations the problem is you know kind
of saying what it means to be doing
something like what we're doing right I
mean I I kind of this isn't quite an
answer to your question but I but I sort
of am of the belief that you know things
like the flash crash or even like the Oh
eight crash you know the broader
crashing oh eight I mean there's a sense
in which the more automation we have and
the more data that's available the more
inevitable it is that we're going to
have incidents like that simply because
when you have many many parties that are
all using
something like machine learning on the
same historical data that's going to
correlate our behavior automatically
like without any anybody directly
intentionally trying to copy anybody
else like just take this execution
problem I described if any of you
thought about this problem you would
have come to kind of a reinforcement
learning approach
if you then said well let's go optimize
that you would have ended up with you
know things that were probably
numerically very similar to what we
ended up with in our policies okay so
you know in some sense right I mean
people talk about like the smarts on
Wall Street in the quants and and you
know but but at the end of the day right
the first-order effect here is that our
behavior is being correlated through
shared information and our all kind of
optimizing with respect to that shared
information and this was just not
possible
thirty years ago right the data wasn't
there I mean we could imagine and I
think that that just forced there to be
greater diversity in in kind of the
approaches people took to the same
problem that's kind of being you know
that sport in and so I mean the reason I
relate this to the Oh a crash is that
you know the sort of you know maybe not
the source of the crash but the final
steps which was this liquidity crunch
you know like lo and behold all these
hedge funds suddenly find when they
tried to go start unwinding their
portfolios that we all have the same
portfolios so you know we're all short
Johnson & Johnson and so we're all
trying to buy back those shares to cover
our short positions at the same time and
we all probably got to those portfolios
through this kind of group optimization
so if you put together these kind of
algorithms and potential correlation
that actually has some very significant
implications for whether you should use
continuous versus batch options which
gets back to Eric's paper so I think
that this could actually be a really
interesting combination of demonstrating
for very job I agree I think there's
great research opportunities though
though you can see I'm coming from this
other side of the fence which you know
is kind of deeply mired in the details
of the way the exchange is currently
work and so I think the hard thing in
this to sort of formulate research
questions here is sort of what details
can you safely throw out and remain
relevant to actual practice
and which are essential and I don't you
know it's a hard hard question in
general but very hard in financial
markets
yeah so I you are you ever going to take
the signature of another hitting from
like oh um we haven't we have we don't
spend time really looking at that
because we're not we're actually not
engaged in hft per se we we we need to
deal with hfts as counterparties I'm
sure we're trading with them all of the
time every day I mean you you anybody
who's buying or selling stocks at some
point is indirectly you know trading
with them as a counterparty because
they're a very large fraction of the
trading volume but it is definitely
possible to do this I mean you can
definitely after the fact like tomorrow
you will see what this must indicate
executed by that yeah I mean it would it
would be a statistical knowledge right
you wouldn't actually say you wouldn't
be able to go and say like well you know
look at this sequence of I mean because
people are breaking up their orders over
time and and and and venues right so you
wouldn't be able to say okay you know
I'm going to mark in red each one of the
trades there was a child order of some
large block trade that somebody was
trying to do if you definitely be able
to say it's extreme you know just given
the statistics historically and in this
period it's quite likely that there was
you know some large party trying to
execute a high-volume trade in a short
period of time those kinds of signatures
are definitely in in the in the data and
you don't need kind of super super I
mean it would it would be available even
from just like the execution date like
trading quote data you wouldn't need to
do like limit order book reconstruction
to see those kinds of signatures it
would let people go to lunch if we're
going to have any chances starting on
time thanks